Metta Bhavana.
Développer la bienveillance.
Développer l'amour bienveillant.
Tout d'abord, nous devons nous réunir dans un état calme et pacifique.
Donc tout d'abord, nous devons nous installer dans un état tranquille et paisible.
Ressentir la respiration comme neutre et plaisante.
Quand nous pratiquons Vipassana, nous développons la qualité d'équanimité.
Mais cette équanimité peut être corrompue en indifférence.
Pour arrêter cela, nous devons pratiquer Metta.
Et pour empêcher cela, nous pratiquons Metta.
Donc, dans votre pratique quotidienne, assurez-vous que vous terminez chaque pratique avec une ou deux minutes de Metta.
Cela veut dire que quelle que soit notre compréhension de vipassana, celle-ci sera transformée en une attitude.
Donc une attitude n'est pas une émotion.
Nous pouvons aider quelqu'un même si nous ne le sentons pas de le faire.
Nous pouvons être bons avec quelqu'un même si nous ne l'aimons pas.
Donc dans les écritures du Bouddha, Metta a vraiment beaucoup d'importance.
Donc Metta c'est vraiment cette relation de base que nous devrions développer
entre nous, mais vraiment avec tous les êtres.
Metta, ça veut dire toutes les bonnes qualités que vous attendriez d'un ami, d'un bon ami.
Donc, si nous avons développé la bienveillance envers quelqu'un, les deux autres caractéristiques illimités vont surgir naturellement.
Elles s'appellent illimités, sans limite.
Si un bon ami à moi est dans le malheur, le désir de l'aider va naître, sera là.
Naturellement.
La compassion apparaît naturellement de Metta.
De la même manière, si un bon ami à moi est heureux, tout va bien pour lui, je suis heureux pour lui.
Donc, à partir de Metta, la joie pour autrui apparaît naturellement.
Le Bouddha appelle ces qualités illimitées parce qu'on peut les développer à l'infini.
C'est comme les chiffres.
Quel que soit le chiffre, on pourrait toujours rajouter un de plus.
Elles s'appellent aussi les Brahma Vihara.
Donc la demeure des dieux les plus élevés, des divinités les plus élevées.
Donc ça veut dire que ce sont des états d'esprit les plus développés que nous pouvons créer.
Donc les quatre caractéristiques illimitées sont l'équanimité.
Donc l'équanimité va empêcher que ces qualités soient corrompues par leurs ennemis les plus proches.
L'amour est corrompu par l'attachement.
Comme aimer seulement ceux que nous aimons.
Donc la compassion est corrompue par le chagrin.
Et la joie est corrompue par
Et la joie est corrompue par trop d'excitation.
Donc développer Metta, c'est facile.
Donc, tout simplement, nous faisons venir à l'esprit certaines catégories de gens et nous leur offrons nos bénédictions.
Et nous pouvons choisir les bénédictions que nous voulons.
Mais les bénédictions traditionnelles sont un nombre de quatre.
La première est la sécurité.
Tout le monde souhaite être en sécurité.
Donc des dangers à l'extérieur d'eux, comme la crise financière, économique.
Et la sécurité des dangers à l'intérieur d'eux-mêmes.
Tout le monde souhaite être en bonne santé.
Tout le monde souhaite être heureux.
Personne ne souhaite être mentalement dans la détresse.
Et nous voulons tous vivre une vie qui est à l'aise avec elle-même.
Donc nous souhaitons tous vivre une vie qui soit confortable, dans l'aisance.
Cela ne veut pas dire une vie facile.
Cela veut dire être dans le contentement.
Accepter que les choses sont telles qu'elles sont.
Être content avec ce que nous avons.
d'être content de ce que nous avons donc il ne faut pas confondre cela avec la résignation donc le contentement quand les situations ne vont pas bien
nous permettent d'accepter la situation et de voir les solutions, les possibilités.
Mais quand il y a résignation, alors à ce moment-là, nous ne voyons pas les possibilités et cela conduit au désespoir.
Donc nous commençons la pratique de metta avec des gens que nous connaissons.
Mais au moment où nous débutons la pratique de metta, peut-être que le cœur ou notre vie émotionnelle ne va pas bien, ne se sent pas bien.
Peut-être que nous nous sentons un peu dépressifs.
Peut-être que nous nous sentons un peu déprimés.
Mais donc nous essayons de mettre ces états, tels qu'ils sont, de côté.
Comme lorsque nous parquons une voiture.
Et nous, comme ça, nous pratiquons les états au-dessus.
Et donc, c'est comme si, en quelque sorte, nous pratiquions Metta par-dessus.
Et après un certain temps, vous allez vous apercevoir que le cœur va se mettre à résonner avec cette attitude.
Et nous allons commencer à ressentir des sensations, des sentiments agréables et bons dans le cœur et dans le corps.
Quand nous offrons ces bénédictions, certaines personnes aiment utiliser des couleurs.
Ou certaines personnes aiment ressentir du chaud qui vient de leur cœur vers la personne.
Ou certaines personnes aiment ressentir la chaleur qui émane de leur cœur en direction de la personne.
Donc, tout ce qui peut vous aider à développer cette attitude est bon.
Donc, souvenez-vous les quatre bénédictions.
Well, happy and contented.
Puisses-tu être en sécurité, bien portant, heureux et content.
Bring now somebody to mind who has helped you in your life, a benefactor.
Donc, amenez maintenant à l'esprit quelqu'un qui vous a fait du bien, un bienfaiteur.
Et en même temps que vous avez cette image dans votre tête, offrez-leur vos bénédictions.
Soyez sain, bien, heureux et content.
Puisses-tu être en sécurité, bien portant, heureux et dans le contentement.
Donne à l'esprit ceux qui sont proches et chers de nous.
Amenez à l'esprit les gens qui nous sont chers et proches.
Et lorsque vous avez l'image dans votre esprit, offrez-leur vos bénédictions.
Amenez à votre esprit vos collègues, vos amis, qui que vous souhaitiez.
Amenez à l'esprit des personnes neutres que vous croisez mais que vous ne connaissez pas.
Tournez, dirigez maintenant ce courant de bienveillance vers nous-mêmes.
Puissage à transécurité, bien portant, heureux et dans le contentement.
Et répétez-le gentiment vers nous-mêmes.
Répétez cela plusieurs fois doucement à nous-mêmes.
Dans le cœur de bienveillance, amenez maintenant une personne avec qui vous avez des difficultés.
Et maintenant, nous pouvons commencer à irradier cette énergie autour de nous.
Pour commencer, avec nous, dans cette pièce.
May we be safe, well, happy and contented.
Puissions-nous être en sécurité, bien portants, heureux et dans le contentement ?
Radiant cette énergie à nos voisins.
Donc là, nous pouvons nous relocaliser à l'endroit où nous vivons.
Et à partir de là, irradié à toutes les personnes dans notre pays.
Pour toutes les personnes en Europe.
Toutes les personnes sur la Terre.
Et donc, au moment où vous incluez toute la Terre, parcourez les endroits où il y a particulièrement de la souffrance.
Et pour terminer, rayonner vers tous les êtres dans toutes les directions.
Donc nous allons le faire dans les six directions, devant nous, derrière nous, sur notre gauche, sur notre droite, en dessous et en dessus.
Offrons notre bienveillance à tous les êtres devant nous.
Tous les êtres derrière, à l'arrière.
tous les êtres sur notre gauche tous les êtres sur notre droite
Tous les êtres en dessous de nous.
et vers tous les êtres dans toutes les directions.
Que tous les êtres soient heureux.
Sādhu, sādhu, sādhu.